Film Courage: Have you ever given up on a
script because you’ve lost interest?
Gary Goldstein: Here and there…you know
I generally don’t start writing something
unless I’ve done outlining and enough exploration
of the idea to know it’s worth going to
script.
Particularly if I am writing somethings on
spec, there are definitely things I’ve written
on spec that…a few things I started and
for some reason I’ve just sort of abandoned
because I felt like I can go back and finish
this sometime if I want to.
But it’s not great enough, it’s not going
to be unique enough, so it becomes a bit of
an exercise.
But by and large I’ve always tried not to
start writing something unless it felt like
something I was going to be able to finish
or that it was really worth doing.
It’s like reading a book.
It’s like if I go to the trouble of starting
to read a book, I might as well finish it,
you know?
But…unless an idea is terrible.
We don’t always have great ideas.
Sometimes there is just not enough there.
But I usually can know that in the outline
stage to save me the hardship of writing the
script and having to sort of like squash it.
Film Courage: So what if you meet with writer
who is new to the industry or baby writer
(whatever you want to call them) and they
just have a slew of unfinished scripts?
Gary Goldstein: Well there’s a reason you
have a slew of unfinished scripts.
Especially if you are starting off writing,
you need one or two good solid finished scripts.
So when I hear somebody has a slew of unfinished
scripts, it means that they are not really
picking and choosing their stories well.
That they are not passionate enough about
the story or they are cheating themselves
out of what the story is about or they are
just trying to write a thriller just because
they think it is going to sell or something
like that.
And a lot of people start writing without
having the necessary tools.
I think everybody thinks “You know, I can
write.”
But they don’t really understand structure.
I’m not saying you have to take a course
in it but you have to have done your homework
in one way or another and understand how to
tell a story cinematically or for television
and not everybody has done that.
Some people just jump in and they’re not
really ready.